Now we're gonna take a look at working with some materials.
Now, as you can see, this scene uses a car,
but you can do this in any type of template
or scene project that you have created.
Mentioning of the car,
there are a lot of brand new car paint available,
which makes even more dramatically much more high res,
but we're gonna work within our lake housing
as we were earlier.
So let's go ahead and take a look at that.
So firstly, it's just like everything else.
It's a drag and drop type of environment.
So you merely go to the materials in your library
and choose what type of material you wish to drag and drop
onto your object.
And that's it, really that simple.
And we're gonna jump in and we're actually gonna do that.
But before we move in,
let's take a look at the eyedropper icon,
which we will access here in a second.
Now what you'll do is you'll click on the object
that you wish to change the material.
And then we're gonna take a look at the details
or its own set of properties and which to work with.
And here are some of the other types
of material properties available.
So let's hop into Twinmotion now and take a look.
I'm gonna go ahead and try and change,
let's say this background here.
And we'll see right now there is just nothing ceramic.
So let's go ahead and go to our materials.
So you come up here to your library, go to materials,
and let's say maybe we want a stone type background.
It's kind of cool, the stack stone.
So you can just drag and drop that right under there.
And you will see it automatically takes place,
takes the place of the original stone.
Now you can hit Control Z
to bring it back to what you had before.
And this brings up another point of the configuration
where you could have it stored.
So you could switch in between to kind of compare.
So keep that in the back of your mind.
I'm gonna go ahead and drag this back on here.
And we'll come over here to the details.
I didn't mention you can edit what you have here.
So right now it has zero grunge.
So we could add some grunge
if you wanted to for the wall.
You can even affect the color or the luminosity of it.
As you can see, I'm just kind of bringing it up and down.
And there are ways to edit the UVs.
Right now it's off for Triplanner.
Triplanner is great for when you're worried
about let's say repeating tiles.
So in this case, as you saw, we put the tiles up there.
That's actually the surface.
So that's why we're still seeing
some large tile like look,
because we just applied a material over an object.
So there are bricks literally there.
So they have, you know, some grooving
and that's your normal map.
So we aren't gonna get into that,
but that just basically throws the high and lows.
So that's why it's not all consistent all the way across
because we didn't get rid of the actual object.
If it were, let's say like flat like this one,
it would appear a lot differently.
We're not gonna worry about that right now,
but the Triplanner would take care of the repeating.
So like you may see like in a grass pattern,
you'll see repeated little like dots
or something throughout.
This is a great way to take care of that.
But again, that's a little outside of what we wanna do.
So again, we're just gonna hop on down past that.
We're gonna look at some of these other things.
You can even change the roughness.
We'll see kind of smooth it out and more roughness.
We'll go to details.
You can even do more.
You can add a texture directly invert,
change your specular, even a clear coat.
Now that's great for your,
let's say the metallics that you're working with.
You can enable it and, you know, increase the roughness
and you'll see you get some changes here in the patterns.
Not as a specific as you would see like in a car,
but still there it is.
Now here are all of the other settings.
As I mentioned, there are quite a few here.
We're not gonna get into that right now
because that is beyond what we do,
but feel free to take some time
and really play around with these settings
to get a better sense of what you want.
Now we're gonna go ahead and move on to lighting.
If you wanna take some time to go through here
and change the various materials to something you may like,
you could even go over here into the table, for example,
and you could change the material of the table
if you wanted to.
Let's say you wanted it to be a slate stone
or maybe some other kind of thing.
Let's just say a stone wall.
You know, oh, that's great.
It's very King Arthur kind of looking,
but anyway, yeah, feel free.
Go through here, change some of the things out,
but we're gonna work next with the lighting.
So let's get started into that.